it keeps on getting worse for Panthers
fans they lost to the Bears on Thursday
Night Football and they had to witness
Bryce young who went first overall lose
to a quarterback who went undrafted and
it's another game where Bryce struggled
and was outplayed too side note Tyson
bent currently has more wins than Bryce
but here's what's making the loss even
worse at the moment the Bears own the
Panthers first round pick in next year's
draft so by beating the Panthers last
night they now have a higher chance of
Landing two picks in the top three and
depending on what the Cardinals do for
the rest of their season the Bears could
end up with the first two picks so what
the only thing that can make this better
for Panthers fans brce young has to
Simply play better and live up to the
trade but right now it's looking like a
win-win for the Bears